emmanuel macron était sur l'île cette
semaine il a annoncé qu'il était prêt à
inscrire le statut de l'île dans la
constitution est ce que vous êtes prêts
à voter une telle révision pas forcément
sur la façon dont il imagine si gignac
si j'ai combien vous prie il imagine le
placer dans un article remaniée de
l'article 72 lors de la prochaine
réforme constitutionnelle mais qui aura
à mon avis un défaut c'est que son idée
finalement c'est d'en faire pratiquement
un droit commun possiblement pour toutes
les régions nous ne sommes pas d'accord
pensons qu'il ya peut-être une exception
corse en tout cas il ya eu des votes le
suffrage universel a montré
manifestement que les nationalistes
aujourd'hui était majoritaire qu'à leurs
idées donc il faut en prendre compte
mais nous pensons que ça doit être des
exceptions et non pas le détricotage du
coup d'une république une et indivisible
y compris dans les institutions et donc
c'est pour ça que par exemple je serai
plus favorable à l'intégrer dans
l'article 74 dans lesquels il y à déjà
aujourd'hui des régions qui ont des dés
dès qu'ils font exception fr
d'institutions notation c'est déjà le
cas aux corses à département sont liées
à la la la la
au territoire donc on voit bien que déjà
il exception il ya wallis et futuna il
ya il ya nouvelle calédonie je serai
plus avoir à ce que vous comprenez le
désarroi des nationalistes après cette
semaine un petit 10 baron n'a pas été
entendu emmanuel macron nous ignore
écoutez moi je pense que sur cette
question il faut l'aborder de manière
très concrète nous on part d'une
principe c'est que la république est une
et indivisible pour le peuple
le point de vue là il ya un peuple
français mais par contre sur les
institutions je viens de le dire il ya
des choses qui peuvent évoluer sa déjà
existé bout et notamment en fonction de
l'insularité de l'accord ce qui
évidemment une particularité est encore
une fois dû de ce qui s'explique aussi
par gildas elle ensuite il faut prendre
point par point ces actes faut pas faire
de l'idéologie sur cette question nous
on y va on a parlé à décor ciel députés
à l'assemblée on
on a discuté avec eux on essaye de
comprendre comment on peut faire en
sorte d'avancer pour parce que la pire
des situations ça serait de déboucher
une situation genre catalan en avant c
est de prendre en compte leurs
revendications par la cik 74 c'est ce
que demandent les nationalistes donc
vous soutenez leur demande sur ce point
de ce point de vue là à partir du moment
où vous l'avez compris nous remettons
pas en question
l'unicité du peuple français parce que
là c'est la question la citoyenneté
politique et d'après ce qu'ils nous ont
dit ils sont d'accord avec çà sert que
ils sont d'accord avec l'idée de dire ce
qui définit la citoyenneté c'est là la
citoyenneté politique
deuxièmement ils sont d'accord de dire
qu' il ne il ne vise pas la dépendance
dont qui sont pour rester dans la
république donc il ya un peuple français
qui est définie par son appartenance à
la république
au niveau institutionnel nous on préfère
des choses qui soient des exceptions et
je vous le dis qu'il ne fasse pas cas
d'école
eca qui propageraient quelque part un
détricotage de ce qu'est la france
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas surnommé
mel macron soit d'accord avec ça c'est
ce qui m'inquiète c'est tant mieux